The Joe Rogan experience. There's a
lot of places like that. Um, we're,
we're animals are dependent on people.
They were depending on people to feed
them and it's a, it's a little squirrely.
Like there's a place in,
I think it's Jamaica where people
swam with wild pigs now while Bahamas.
Bahamas. Yeah. Yeah. No wild pigs
generally avoid people. Yeah.
They don't want to have anything to
do with you and they're dangerous.
They're sketchy. Yeah. Wild boars
are nuts. Yeah. But in this place,
people have been feeding
these things for so long.
They have trips like tourist
trips where people fly in,
feed these pigs and swim around with them.
Pig Island,
they got wild pigs that are
constantly being fed by people.
But a friend of a friend went there
and someone they were with God bit.
Oh yeah, I've heard they put them
in the ass a bit. One of the,
one of the pigs bit them in the ass and
it was because they didn't have any food
or something like that. Then
didn't offer me any. Thank you.
You have to keep feeding them
throughout the whole thing.
It tells you all about it,
that they,
that they get really ornery and they
get really annoyed. Fuck you. Fuck you.
Fuck you just drown it. Just put it right
under. Nah, Bro. They're strong. No,
they are.
You can't fuck with those scents.
Creepy animal because they're beautiful
and they're sweet and the like. Pigs are,
there are weird. One I know has
their look as cool. I'm a dog lover.
I love dogs. Pigs are almost like
a dog and maybe smarter clothes.
Their PR, well, probably
definitely smarter,
but they liked the way that
we react to people. Look,
if you feed them and you're their friend,
you become their buddy,
but are you against eating them? No,
but also look, cause I've killed them.
I know they're delicious. Wild ones,
but wild ones are different, man. Right?
Because they're out there
hustling. Okay. They don't,
they're not in this fucking pen getting
slop all day trying to fatten them up.
Right.
It's hard to get fat out there.
They're out there so much more lean
meat out there. They're much leaner,
but they're also vicious man. They're
V to get, they grow these giant tusks.
They have these big fucking fangs.
The thing is they're the same
species as the domestic pit.
So same animal, just once one's, one's
pampered and one's not exactly bring up.
Have you ever seen have Salinas,
do you know what have all the is are so
in Arizona peccary well when I saw that
it looks just like a pig.
That was when I first,
when I first moved to Arizona
I saw one and I was like, oh,
what the fuck is that thing?
And my buddy was like, no,
no, no, don't quote it. They,
they'll come right at you.
They will fucking go for your legs bad
because they're real low to the ground.
But he's like, they'll start spearing
you and they'll come at your legs.
And one time I was valuing in college and
I was up way in the up in the mountain
and some dudes, you know, some private,
huge private residence and there
with packs, I mean packs of them.
And I could hear them rustling around
and they were like positioning themselves
because I was, we were parking cars
where they were living and I was like,
we can't park cars up there.
You can tell they started
to get aggressive in jumping
and diving at the cars.
Yeah, they were getting fucking
annoyed, man. They did. I was like,
we can't go back up there.
We're going to get fucked up
by these little bullshit pigs.
You know where Stan hope lives out in
Bisbee, which is real close to the border.
They have them all over the
place yet they're everywhere.
They killed one of his friend's dog.
They do kill dog. They, well they,
they're known to kill cats more,
but yeah,
they do kill dogs because dogs are about,
depending on the size of your dog,
there are some of those,
some dogs could those things up
because they're not that big, but they,
they're known as murder cats.
It was a small dog I think,
and I think they flanked it and this
came at it from the sides to the park.
The rip apart a dog.
What do you do when someone,
something like that kills your dog?
Are you out with a shotgun?
Trying to find the rest of them did.
I was trying to kill coyotes after they
ate my chickens and I don't give, I mean,
I love chickens. Like they're cute.
They're my friends. But when they died,
a couple of them died of just natural
causes. Yeah. I'd be like, aw,
poor little guy. But if my dog died,
it'd be really sad. You know what I mean?
There's, it's a different
relationship, different.
So when these coyotes killed my chickens,
I sat out there on the porch with a bow
and a rangefinder waiting to fuck them
up for days. I even tied one of the
dead chickens that they killed to a pot,
like a, you know, that you would
plant is in, what are you doing James?
Um,
the Po that you plant things in.
And I sat in the middle of the yard
as bait and I sat up there waiting.
One of them came and my daughter
screamed out, a Guy Audi, and I'm like,
God damn got gotta teach her how to hunt.
Like I had that mother fucker that's,
it was inside. He was inside of 40 yards
and he was creeping in. I was like, oh,
I had to do is get to my spot and I
would have probably got a shot. Yeah.
How 40 yards. That's a far away was he
was at 40 yards when my daughter scream.
Oh Shit.
Well then it was like freaked out so I
stayed up there for a few hours longer.
What's the first, what's the furthest that
you feel comfortable hitting a target?
[inaudible] target w you know there's a
difference between something that's the
size of a coyote.
Coyote is only like they're not paying,
their body might be like a foot, a foot
and a half. They're not big at all.
Yeah, they're tiny from top to
bottom. So what we're trying to,
if you're trying to hit them in the
vitals, you don't have a lot to aim at.
It's a very Smith's big
dot. Yeah. You want to be,
you'd want it to be fairly close.
I think about that all the time.
Bow with a rifle, you could
shoot him. It's not that,
that's not something totally different.
I tried to kill him.
I only grew up shooting rifles.
I never shot a gun until I
was in my twenties but rifles,
I was so used to shooting.
I got so accustomed to shooting it and
then I try to bow once and that was
unbelievably fucking hard. You
should learn. It'd be fun for it.
You can always come here and practice.
I'll come next time.
John Dudley comes into town. I'll have
them a hook. You up on attachment. Yeah,
they'd love it man. Not even like to
go hunting, but just to shoot targets.
It's really fun. And I like guns though.
That game out there. I do too. Yeah.
That game out there that I have that uh,
techno hunt gay dude.
Once you get into that and
start playing that, what's your,
should add a screen fonts. You're fucking
good at it. Oh, fun. I had Corey Anderson,
UFC light heavyweight.
He's a bow hunter.
I had him here the other day and he
was playing it cause he could, oh,
he's really good. But you could tell me
he practiced. He so fucking elite athlete.
Of course he's going to be a
good thing. Yeah, that's true.
What do they not also fighter?
So he's got this discipline mindset
and you know, he's just on the ball.